i was thinking about this today in
preparation for our interview
you have had so many iconic roles
so many great performances yet
one of the things that probably
uh you might be best known for or among
your best known p
performances would be in the start out
live sketch cowbell
have you found that to be true yes
it was a very good sketch and and
but i i don't understand why why it
follows me around like it does
and how does it follow you around give
us an example
oh you know i i it doesn't i was in a
restaurant in singapore
and the couple at the next table uh at
one
point the guy said to me uh chris you
know this salad needs more cowbell
[Laughter]
and i thought i've i it's gone too far
you're in singapore you're in singapore
and it follows you
yes that says and uh i don't know why
that sketch became so famous
it's mysterious you know how some things
catch on
yes it is mysterious i think it has
something to do with your
voice and the way you said cowbell i
really believe if anyone else had done
that role
it would not that sketch would not have
endured the way it does i give you
credit for that
it's a fine sketch but i think it's the
way you said cowbell
well it was also it was will ferrell and
you know what is it to
meet the reaper or
something about the reaper oh yes uh uh
don't fear the reaper
don't fear the reaper yeah yeah we'll
you know
yes i'm sure all those were all great
elements but i think you pulled it all
together
well thanks but it's it's uh
kind of run its course no it hasn't
it's gonna keep going
no matter what else you achieve in your
career it will keep going and there's
nothing we can do about it